(Applause)
And yet,
and yet,
with all of our talk in this culture about moon shots,
too few members of Generation Possible and those of us who mentor them
are taking on nuclear weapons.
It's as if there's a taboo.
But I remember something Kennedy said that has really stuck with me,
and that is something to the effect
that humans can be as big as the solutions
to all the problems we've created.
No problem of human destiny, he said,
is beyond human beings.
I believe that.
And I bet a lot of you here believe that, too.
And I know Generation Possible believes it.
So it's time to commit to a date.
Let's end the nuclear weapons chapter
on the 100th anniversary of its inception.
After all, by 2045, we will have held billions of people hostage
to the threat of nuclear annihilation.
Surely, 100 years will have been enough.
Surely, a century of economic development
and the development of military strategy
will have given us better ways to manage global conflict.
Surely, if ever there was a global moon shot worth supporting,
this is it.
Now, in the face of real threats --
for instance, North Korea's recent nuclear weapons tests,
which fly in the face of sanctions --
reasonable people disagree
about whether we should maintain some number of nuclear weapons
to deter aggression.
But the question is: What's the magic number?
Is it a thousand?
Is it a hundred? Ten?
And then we have to ask:
Who should be responsible for them?
I think we can agree, however,
that having 15,000 of them represents a greater global threat
to Jasmine's generation than a promise.
So it's time we make a promise
of a world in which we've broken the stranglehold
that nuclear weapons have on our imaginations;
in which we invest in the creative solutions
that come from working backward from the future we desperately want,
rather than plodding forward from a present
that brings all of the mental models and biases of the past with it.
It's time we pledge our resources as leaders across the spectrum
to work on this old problem in new ways,
to ask, "How might we?"
How might we make good on a promise
of greater security for Jasmine's generation
in a world beyond nuclear weapons?
I truly hope you will join us.
Thank you.
(Applause)